[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 la
chute de kaboul c'était il ya six mois
on se souvient de ces images de chaos de
cette fouille davd en tentant de fuir
les talibans reprenaient le pouvoir
vingt ans après en avoir été chassés six
mois plus tard le pays est meurtri par
la famine l'économie sinistrée les
femmes banni des écoles et de l'espace
public du monde du travail
les etats unis ont bloqué l'accès à la
quasi totalité des avoirs de la banque
centrale afghane le fmi et la banque
mondiale ont suspendu les aides ainsi
que l'union européenne joe biden prévoit
maintenant de consacrer la moitié des 7
milliards de dollars d'actifs afghans à
l'indemnisation des familles victimes
des attentats du 11 septembre
l'autre moitié devrait être reversée
sous forme d' aide humanitaire en
afghanistan une décision qui suscite
l'indignation des afghans alors
l'afghanistan et ils en péril les
talibans obtiendront-ils un déblocage de
l'aide internationale
faut-il négocier avec ce régime on en
débat avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés jean car paiera à
bonsoir le journaliste écrivain
spécialiste du proche-orient du
moyen-orient et de l'afghanistan votre
dernier livre jean pierre kaboul
l'humiliante défaite et c'est aux
éditions des équateurs
avec nous également shoukria haïdar
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
fondatrice et présidente de
l'association on égare soutien aux
femmes d'afghanistan une association
créée en
1996 vous êtes on peut dire une
féministe franco-afghane exilé en france
depuis l'invasion soviétique en 1981
bienvenue dans ce débat frédéric joly
est avec nous porte parole du comité
international de la croix-rouge en
france auteur du blog l'humanitaire dans
tous ses états bienvenue à vous
également avec nous sonia ghezali notre
correspondante correspondante france 24
qui est au pakistan avec nous m'ont soir
sonia est bienvenue
bonsoir nous entend sonia la suite de
kaboul s'était donc il ya six mois vous
savez et bien six mois plus tard on peut
dire que les talibans sont là est bel
bien là jean pierre perrin kaboul
l'humiliante et fait 1 pour reprendre le
titre de votre livre humiliante défaite
pour les américains et on peut dire quoi
victoire glorieuse des talibans
ko victoire par ko même s'il ya pas eu
de défaite militaire de la part des
américains le fait qu'ils aient engagé
autant d'hommes le matériel le plus
sophistiqué de la terre qu'ils soient
seconde et par l'otan la plus grande
force internationale la mieux équipée
avec quand même un volume d'hommes assez
importants sont défaits par une bande
d'irrégulier à quelques dizaines de
milliers d'hommes je crois que ça
devrait faire réfléchir
même pas le moindre acte de contrition
de l'otan ni des américains sur cette
défaite c'est aussi à signaler ils ont
quand même été
battue lui pas militairement encore une
fois mais cet enlisement qui c'est qui a
perduré pendant une vingtaine d'années
eh bien ma foi ça que c'est quand même
une défaite qui certes c'est pas des
nuits de fou mais c'est quand même une
magnifique victoire pour les talibans
qui était d'ailleurs célébré comme tel
j'ai pris comme tel on peut dire six
mois après jean pierre perrin le régime
taliban n'est toujours pas reconnue par
la communauté internationale
je crois même qu'il n'a marqué aucun
point c'est à dire ils ont marqué oui
n'ont marqué aucun point en ce sens qu'
aucun pays ne les a reconnus au moins le
précédent régime des taliban de 1996 à
2001 avait été reconnue par trois pays
et pas des moindres puisque le pakistan
l'arabie saoudite les émirats là aucun
pays ne les a reconnus donc ils n'ont
marqué aucun point alors effectivement
il ya des avancées sur le plan
humanitaire mais en même temps ils n'ont
marqué aucun point à l'intérieur du pays
c'est à dire que la population
finalement ce qui pouvait s'accommoder
du régime à cause de la famine à cause
des conditions déplorables de vie
commencent à fuir à s'en aller à à se
rebeller éventuellement sans le montrer
évidemment contre eux ça c'est un
premier point mais n'ont marqué aucun
point en ce sens qu'ils n'ont pas élargi
leur gouvernement il n'y a toujours pas
de technocrates points très importants
n'y a pas de femmes il ya quelques
représentants des minorités tout à fait
symbolique donc aucun point de nice
hurle à l'intérieur ni à l'extérieur si
ce n'est une ébauche de dialogue avec
des humanitaires pour faire venir là une
aide afin de très cette famine qui est
l'une des pires qu'ait connues le pays
frédéric joly selon l'onu on assiste à
la plus grande crise humanitaire au
monde avec le yémen sur les 38 millions
d'habitants du pays 23 millions sont
menacées par la famine soit 55% de la
population
est ce le constat de la croix-rouge et
avez vous est ce que la croix rouge a
toujours accès aux pays aux populations
afghanes
le constat le chiffre que vous avancez
depuis la moitié de la population a
besoin d'une assistance humanitaire et
est réel est vrai c'est extrêmement
difficile vous imaginez bien par en plus
d en plein hiver des températures
négatives qui descendent à plus de 2 de
moins dix et des gens qui n'ont plus
vraiment les moyens de se chauffer dans
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'endroits le
cicr a accès disons que ça fait très
longtemps qu'il le cicr travaille en
afghanistan ça fait plusieurs décennies
depuis 1982 et ses sirènes présence
permanente et il s'est adapté au gré de
l'évolution du conflit adapter une
réponse opérationnelle aujourd'hui face
comme vous l'avez souligné dans votre
lancement dans les différents sujets
dont ce qu'on dit des différents
intervenants
évidemment que le pays est dans une
crise économique est véritablement en
situation d'effondrement et que m'avait
toute la palette opérationnel que nous
avons depuis des décennies nous
concentrons désormais nos efforts sur le
système de santé qui est en train de
totalement s'effondrer et c'est la
première fois peut-être dans les temps
des séries sert qu'on que l'on fait un
soutien aussi massif sur des hôpitaux
puisque nous payons les salaires de 10
mille agents de santé nous soutenons 30
28 hôpitaux dans tout dans tout
l'afghanistan dont 8 e qui sont des chu
donc il forme aussi des futurs médecins
bref on essaye de récupérer avec en
collaboration avec les autorités
afghanes aujourd'hui est bien un système
de santé totalement défaillante qui
souffrent de toutes les pénuries que ce
soit bien évidemment en termes de
médicaments mais aussi en termes de flux
de fluides puisqu'il faut du carburant
pour alimenter les groupes électrogènes
qui font tourner l'électricité qui
permettent un accès à l'eau et s'occuper
des malades chroniques enfin bref essai
prendre en charge le plus largement
possible
ça pourra pas durer des mois ou des
années en tout cas que ses soeurs
s'occupe pour le moment depuis plusieurs
mois est bien de la situation du système
de santé qui est évidemment extrêmement
infectés par tous ceux qui par toutes
les restrictions aujourd'hui auxquels
doit faire face la population afghane
l'afghanistan je vous propose d'écouter
un extrait d'un reportage un reportage
de roméo langlois et de sonia ghezali ça
se passe dans un camp de réfugiés
c'était il ya quelques mois vous allez
voir qu'une mère vend un de ses enfants
pour pouvoir survivre
quand sa fille de 13 ans est tombé
gravement malade
cette mère de famille a dû prendre une
décision terrible pour pouvoir acheter
le traitement
vendre sa petite dernière âgée donne en
main une main sur une majorité
parlementaire
comment convaincre mais quand même aux
halles à dire une ambassade à quatre
salles vers la kaaba sur le goût mastic
à old boys public qui bossent 2014 verra
à garda mirror crabos à gameiro
l'attaquant jon boscia mois à la fin
sonia sonia ghezali vous avez réalisé
donc ce reportage ce grand reporter le
dock avec roméo langoat steve vous très
grande détresse évidemment qu'on voit là
vous avez tourné cette séquence dans le
nord de kaboul dans des camps d'ailleurs
qui n'existent plus parce qu'aujourd'hui
cette situation de pauvreté c'est même
généralisée
oui exactement et alors ce camp là se
trouvaient dans le nord de kaboul à
rayhana qui a un quartier résidentiel et
c'est là en fait où plusieurs familles
qui avaient fui les violences qui
avaient lieu dans les provinces où les
taliban justement combattez contre les
forces de sécurité afghanes pour prendre
le pouvoir ben justement ces familles en
fête ont fui ces violences elles sont à
olivet se réfugie à kaboul un peu avant
l'arrivée des talibans dans la capitale
le 15 août et elles ont vécu vraiment
l'enfer surtout avec l'arrivée de
l'hiver qui les a vraiment plongés dans
une plus grande précarité et dans une
plus grande détresse on a donc assisté
effectivement à des scènes de violence
lors de distributions de nourriture par
exemple des choses qu'on n'avait jamais
vu avant et puis des femmes qui
expliquait avoir donné leurs enfants les
champs de quelques afghani pour pouvoir
simplement nourrir le reste de la
famille ou paix ou payés par dont les
médicaments pour pour des nourrissons
par exemple malades ce qu'il faut dire
quand même c'est que
vendre des enfants fait quelque chose
qui se produisaient déjà en afghanistan
avant lé talibans sont arrivés au
pouvoir ont pris le pouvoir dans un pays
qui allait déjà mal et dans le nord de
l'afghanistan notamment avec la
sécheresse qui s'est répétée année après
année on a vu des situations similaires
avec des familles donner leurs enfants
contre quelques algues annie pour
pouvoir survivre sous kreia haidar alors
six mois après leur arrivée au pouvoir
que la situation des femmes afghanes
manifestement selon une trentaine
d'experts indépendants les talibans
tentent d'effacer progressivement les
femmes et les filles de la vie publique
en afghanistan et la répression vise
particulièrement les militantes les
dirigeants de la société civile et
femmes juges et procureurs les
journalistes
c'est ça la situation aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup et je remercie notre ami de
reportages qui a faim on va écouter
l'objectif des taliban c'est pourquoi
elle vise les femmes parce que je dis
auparavant plusieurs reprises dans
l'état libre s'est pas renforcé
émergentes de l'afghanistan c'est pas
une force pour prendre le gouvernement
pour vous gouvernez pour s'occuper de
pays si une force pour détruire pour
casser pour vraiment brimer la
population et faire de sorte que les
gens soient oubliées d'équité de mourir
de faim des maladies et des dépressions
et ceux qui restent il faut que ce soit
des esclaves donc il faut le mettre bien
en tête qu'elle est alimentée par une
force ce sont des milices ont veillé
pour dans ce pays pour tenir pour
détruire pour casser non pas pour
construire ou aider quiconque ils n'ont
pas changé hélas non seulement qu'ils
sont prêts à changer elles ont eu 20 ans
de plus pour bien renforcer leurs
relations avec
les pays arabes et le pakistan ils ont
bien appris ils ont elles sont bien
entraînés ils sont bien organisés donc
maintenant le sauvagerie avec laquelle
les avances en oeuvre des leçons et de
manière systématique et
fait subir les populations c'est
horrible et en même temps durant ses 20
ans ne sont pas arrivés le 15 août tout
ça c'était démarrer avant le jeudi
encore je répète les soldats le
militaire les agents de sécurité
afghanes en atelier ce n'était pas des
gens des salles aux ce n'est pas d'aider
des peureux c'était pas des gens
indignes on a fait 200 à l'intérieur du
gouvernement il y avait des gens qui
travaillent et pour l'épreuve sommes là
pour que
l'état les départements tombent les unes
après les autres dans le mode telle
vente jusqu à l arrivée jusque-là palais
présidentiel où la chambre est né un kit
de pays est dans le pouvoir à ses amis
pour que l mais cela reste de travail
qui lui irait pas faire parce que les
salaires des profs des salaires des
fonctionnaires les célèbres des soldats
les nourritures de soldats tout cela
tout ce désordre comme dit notre ami
il avait les sécheresses tout cela non
l'état d'achat boni pendant d'autres
dernier scellé alors est ce que vd rien
et saufs l'ancien président à le guen
ancien président d'octane exil
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs et en même temps
c'était quand cet accord avec les
américains
accélérer tout
con et le sauvage est tellement bien au
contraire souhaité x 10 x 10 jean pierre
perrin vous êtes d'accord les talibans
parce que vous parlez éventuel mandat
des talibans 2.0 dans votre livre ils
ont changé ou pas ils ont changé en
partie oui c'est à dire c'est plus la
même génération même si les anciens
soins sont aussi là nous nous sommes
vraiment des talibans 2.0 c'est à dire
que cette victoire militaire qui l'ont
emporté en même temps y en avait une qui
se se voyait beaucoup moins c'est celle
qui remportait sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est à dire qu'ils annonçaient leur
offensive en temps réel avec une
maîtrise de l'informatique qui était
assez extraordinaire chez des gens qu'on
qualifie à tort d'ailleurs de moyenâgeux
c'est ça le 2.0 fait sur les femmes
évidemment sur les sociétés et les
femmes il ya toujours les mêmes blocages
mais où je n'aurais pas la même
appréciation que vous mmes c'est que non
ils ne veulent pas la famine non ils ne
veulent pas que les lélés les afghans
soient aussi pauvre que possible au
contraire et bien justement cherché dans
les pays occidentaux une aide et bien
essayé de faire débloquer l'argent qui
est bloqué par les états unis non ils ne
veulent pas que la situation soit aussi
catastrophique qu'elle est non ça c'est
pas vrai il veut l'implication d'un
régime certes qui est ce qu'il est mais
il va nous payer comment qui est un
régime à rigaud reseller général caïques
da brick même si a quand même le ils
sont quand même les talibans 2.0 un
régime archaïque un régime qui se
trament donc cette pré presse oui il
vise particulièrement les familles parce
que c'est un point de blocage et c'est
comme ça aussi qu'ils ont remportée en
partie la guerre ils ont rapporté en
partie la guerre parce qu'ils y passait
dans les villages en disant regardez pas
dans tous les villages les villages du
sud est la jeunesse en disant regardez
américains veulent envoyer vos filles
dans les écoles et c'est intolérable et
que lorsqu'on dit un paysan afghan on va
envoyer sa fille à l'école et n'est pas
toujours d'accord et qui pensent qu'il
faut justement combattre ça et rejoint
des talibans encore une fois c'est pas
tout l'afghanistan mais qui sont les
talibans souvent ce sont des métayers
des paysans sans terre sans éducation
avec évidemment des séminaristes pour un
peu en schématisant pour les guider pour
les contrôler mon les diriger donc on a
quand même une question sociale en
afghanistan qui n'est jamais posée or il
faut la poser ces paysans sans terre
c'est ça ce sont une grande partie
l'armature d'aider des talibans est donc
temps que le
l'afghanistan et d'un des pays les plus
inégalitaires du monde c'est un pays où
il avait d'ailleurs la fraternité aussi
être été un grand mot enfin les tadjik
et les ouzbeks se détestent et ouzbeks
et les pachtouns pareillement les hazara
n'en parlons pas et donc tout ça c'était
s'effaça favorise la matrice talibane
voyez ça ne parte pas de rien il parle
d'une sociale se sont créés à y est
catastrophique
au départ car une section politique
social économique est catastrophique et
prospère sur sur ce terrain mais je
pense que ce que vous dites c'est une
façade comme moi ou on essaie de faire
entendre pour les pauvres l'extérieur
aux salles des populations de l'intérêt
de la gazon ou de l'excès comme son
mentor france il n'est pas un corps elle
est née entre nous darveau se pose même
pas la question dès qu'elle est ni d'où
tu es ce n'est pas la réalité au lycée
immédiatement un afghan rencontre à la
grue l'autre afghans il s'est
immédiatement non seulement de quelle
ethnie mais souvent de quelle tribu lou
que de quelques l'organisme qui je suis
la vienne qui je suis ce sont trois ans
que j'ai j'ai vécu et je suis toujours
en contact alors donc si vous pouvez le
danger tort et j'ai vu que c'est un
débat en tout cas bien sûr écoutez donc
boursiers les jours entendu écouté j'ai
entendu
maintenant revient sur d'oser pas
d'autres bars partez quand je dis qu'est
ou de quels étaient les mots ne veulent
pas la pauvreté des populations elles ne
veulent pas le mal n'est pas plaisant
elles ont forcé ils ont des réseaux le
projet d le délocalisation de
déplacement des compresseurs non non non
non les endroits où elles sont pas des
problèmes des progressions hazaras ou
ouzbeks ou tragiques elle souhaite
libérer les terres pour donner aux
autres mais comme il avait la voix qui
monte donc elles sont obligées d'arrêter
voyez bien vous même camp que l'essai
clinique est alors mal expliquée mais ça
c'est non ça c'est bon on va sortir de
la question et parce qu'on n'a pas
suffisamment de temps je finis ça va
ressembler ce projet politique c'est un
projet politique les pigeons bien sûr le
président mais ça là dessus tout le
monde est d'accord les talibans ont un
projet politique et le président joe
biden a signé lui un décret qui permet
la saisie de sept milliards de dollars
de réserves de la banque centrale
afghane réserves déposées aux etats unis
le président américain souhaite
d'ailleurs qu'une moitié de cette somme
soit réservé pour des demandes
d'indemnisation déposées par des
familles de victimes des attentats du 11
septembre 2001 il prévoit que l'autre
moitié soit consacrée à de l'aide
humanitaire à l'afghanistan mais versés
de manière à ce que l'argent dit il ne
tombe pas aux mains des taliban alors
des manifestations ont eu lieu en
afghanistan aujourd'hui contre cette
mesure
on va écouter ce qu'en dit hamid karzaï
et l'ancien président afghan il est
interviewé par marc perelman pour france
écoutez ce qu'il en dit
ce sont les avoirs du peuple afghan
et le peuple afghan à l'est tout autant
une victime que les victimes de la
tragédie du 11 septembre
tu es donc vous fait que le président
byden saisissent la moitié des réserves
nationales et qui les halles ou à ses
victimes
il s'agit là d'un déni du statut de
victime du peuple afghan c'est
moralement répréhensible
j'y suis oui fortement opposés je suis
opposé à cette décision nous voulons que
l'intégralité de ses avoirs soient
réservés à l'afghanistan
frédéric joly demandant votre réaction
vous qu'elle porte parole du justement
du cicr et que vous parle vous évoquiez
justement le financement propre de ces
hôpitaux votre réaction après cette
décision de joe biden
je pense qu'il est important quand même
de garder à l'esprit qu'il faut que la
communauté internationale se mobilise
pour permettre à la population afghane
de ne pas sombrer plus qu'elle ne l'est
actuellement les besoins sont colossaux
on
concentre vraiment tous nos efforts sur
sur toute l'infrastructure hospitalière
et médical de l'afghanistan mais plus le
temps va passer plus la situation risque
de s'aggraver pour les pour les
populations le cicr depuis des décennies
fait tout l'orthopédie en afghanistan
avec 700 tantôt pedic essentiellement
pour des gens qui ont sauté sur des
mines antipersonnel ou alors qu'ils ont
été victimes des combats ou alors qu
iron qui ont qui ont été blessés par des
débris de bien exploser le cicr
aujourd'hui essayer de prendre en charge
souvent avec le croissant-rouge afghan
est aussi parfois avec deux croix rouge
comme la croix-rouge norvégienne les
infrastructures sanitaires mais les
besoins sont colossaux vous vous ouvriez
le le débat autour des problèmes de
nutrition ceux ci vont continuer à se
poser donc s'il n'y a pas une
mobilisation pour permettre au peuple
afghan de pouvoir
dépasser la crise profonde qu'il est en
train de subir il va falloir que des
politiques effectivement se dépêchent
essayer de régler le problème en tout
cas c'est pas le cicr ou c'est pas les
humanitaires y en a plus beaucoup
aujourd'hui en avant en afghanistan qui
seront à même de pouvoir régler ce
problème là c'est véritablement aux et à
la communauté internationale de prendre
aussi ses responsabilités à sonia les
talibans en tout cas ont menacé de
reconsidérer leur politique vis-à-vis
des etats-unis le talent ils les
talibans même qualifiée de vol cette
saisie des avoirs qu'est ce qu'on en dit
sur place
écouter les opinions sont quasi unanimes
elles sont très très critique à des
états unis c'est très difficile pour la
population afghane de comprendre cette
décision de joe biden alors que le pays
est plongé dans il a une famille sur
trois n'a plus aucun revenu le système
bancaire s'effondre complètement les
tous les entrepreneurs les gens qui
participait à la vie économique ont fuit
le pays d'autres tentes jeu rencontrée
hier un businessman qui m'expliquait
qu'il avait dû fuir parce que ce n'était
plus tenable il n'y a plus de liquidité
en fait en afghanistan et donc c'est
difficile de comprendre cette décision
des états unis sachant que la population
est plongé dans une eau dans une extrême
misère le nombre de personnes qui vend
son vin par exemple a terriblement
augmenté on voit des situations
d'extrême précarité et le danger je vais
citer un analyste qui expliquait que le
danger avec cette décision s'était
finalement de créer une sorte de
cohésion entre une partie de la
population qui savait pas trop où se
positionner par rapport aux talibans et
qui finalement
avait cette rancoeur vis-à-vis des
etats-unis qui a été exacerbée par à
cette décision et qui pourra justement
rallier encore plus de personnes aux
talibans jean pierre perrin donc ça
l'effet inverse en fait cette décision
de joe baïda nord comment la justifie
t'elle est ce que est ce que c'est parce
qu'il ya un certain nombre de ministres
du gouvernement taliban qui sont sur la
liste américaine des terroristes
qu'est-ce qu'il ya encore des liens
entre le taliban d'ailleurs et al qaïda
oui bien sûr enfin les américains
renégocier avec eux des gens qu'ils
avaient eux mêmes placés sur la liste
des personnes les plus recherchées au
monde avec des variantes des récompenses
de 10 millions oui 200 millions de
dollars c'est plus la somme exacte de
cet ordre là on evensen sans leur
absolue que l'actuel ministre de
l'intérieur sirajuddin haqqani si vous
regardez si vous allez sur le site du
fbi a et sa tête est toujours mise à
prix et c'est pourtant lui avec lui que
les et les etats unis ont en partie
négocier l'évacuation de leur force de
kaboul dont vous voyez on est un petit
peu dans nos le summum des ambiguïtés
alors oui je pense que bill donne aussi
franchement les américains ne veulent
plus entendre parler de l'afghanistan
donc qu'ils ne vont pas le contredire
sur cette décision et en plus il doit
faire face à des élections du mid term
il doit faire face à un sénat qui lui
est hostile
doit faire face à isle compris au sein
de son parti à une opposition donc
finalement c'est aussi l'afghanistan et
de lui aussi un problème de politique
intérieure et doit rendre compte alors
j'imagine que c'est aussi pour cette
raison qu'il a coupé la somme en deux
une partie pour les victimes du 11
septembre et l'autre partie donc pour
les pour les les afghans en pleine
souffrance en pleine détresse en pleine
famine shoukria haïdar votre réaction
sur cette décision de joe biden mais
écoutez monsieur je
ne comprends pas c'était politique de
monsieur joe biden parce que cet argent
est la partie de la population de
l'afghanistan ce n'est pas l'argent des
talibans et la ramener à geler acquis
voix suivie de la banque centrale
afghane oui je les par les etats-unis
depuis
les attentats du 11 septembre c'étaient
pas des afghans c'était un crédit bail
et des liens entre ces salles zazie il
ya des liens entre les halles qaïda et
les taliban gouvernement qui n'est pas
reconnu par les états unis par le monde
entier c'est le talent ne sera pas
reconnu mais cet argent et pouvait le
garder violer c'est d'avoir des
populations de la france aux comores
défunt
donc il faut moi je trouve que c'est
injuste c'est injuste il faut et de
l'autre côté j'ai fait appel encore a à
g remercie de notre ami et toutes les
communes les associations l'occasion du
mondial d apporter des lettres à cette
population a manqué est mort de faim
avant qu'elle meure des valeurs frédéric
joly est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
du coup dialoguer avec les talibans
s'asseoir avec eux même si donc on
comprend bien qu'ils n'ont pas à changer
pour pouvoir justement débloquer une
aide qui est toujours gelé qui fait
partie donc des sanctions contre
l'afghanistan
notre préoccupation c'est la même que
l'on a dans tous les contextes de
guerres dans lesquelles nous travaillons
c'est à dire à tous du conflit la
planète aujourd'hui c'est bien
évidemment d'avoir un dialogue avec tous
ceux qui sont d'aidé qui ont maille à
partir avec la situation de conflit la
situation de violence dont bien
évidemment que discutons avec les
talibans qui on a une responsabilité
c'est aussi administrée et gérée à et
gérer un pays le cicr avait une surface
opérationnelles importantes je le disais
avant que ça la visite des détenus que
ce soit le soutien des familles les plus
vulnérables que ce soit la
reconstruction de certains quartiers que
ce soit le soutien économique des plus
pauvres aujourd'hui on continue
évidemment toutes ces actions là mais on
est en train véritablement de se
concentrer sur la dimension médicale et
que l'accès force est de constater que
les 1800 collègues du cicr qui travaille
aujourd'hui en afghanistan et dans
quasiment toutes les grandes villes
toutes les provinces de l'afghanistan et
bien cet accès fonctionne et que nous
pouvons
très sensiblement développer des
opérations d'importance si vous prenez
dans le sud du pays à kandahar vous avez
bien lu c'est ixair mais ruiz qui est
qui a 600 lits et bien nous faisons
passer chaque mois un convoi de 10
camions donc c'est des dizaines de
tonnes qui sont qui alimente entièrement
cet hôpital est que cet accès donc il
laisse sept à crawley jaune exerciez
avec eux les talibans en fait se donne
en tout cas l'apparence de vouloir
négocier tout à fait on se retrouve à
gérer véritablement des segments entiers
de service public je disais tout à
l'heure le carburant ou à ses 700 mille
litres de carburant qui sont distribuées
dans le pays par le cicr afin de pouvoir
améliorer
l'électricité des grosses pénuries
électriques dans les hôpitaux c'est une
catastrophe si a pas d'électricité ou
encore l'accès à l'eau potable on m'a
véritablement le cicr travaille sur des
segments qui sont aujourd'hui
déterminant pour la survie de la
population à sonia puisque vous êtes au
pakistan qu'est ce qu'on en dit au
pakistan à deux ans des élections le
pakistan le grand allié bien sûr des
talibans
donc le terrifie le premier ministre un
discours qui est très clair l'huile est
vraiment en faveur du dialogue avec les
talibans et lors d'une réunion des pays
musulmans il ya deux mois justement il a
appelé la communauté internationale
encore une fois à discuter avec les
taliban à maintenir un dialogue puisque
le premier ministre imran rana ne cesse
de répéter que bien évidemment s'il ya
une grave crise humanitaire ou
sécuritaire en afghanistan le premier
pays qui en paiera les conséquences ce
sera le pakistan le pakistan qui
accueille déjà près de trois millions de
réfugiés afghans sur son sol tout
apprécié que le gym talibans le
précédent
il apparut reconnu dans ce contrairement
aux années 90 soit effectivement le
pakistan avait reconnu non il n'a pas
reconnu parce que le pakistan est dans
une position aujourd'hui assez délicate
il fait face aussi à une crise
économique et il doit lui aussi
maintenir ses relations avec les pays
occidentaux notamment et donc vendre a
dit bien qu'il n'y aura pas de
reconnaissance il n'y a pas de consensus
donc lui de charges vraiment à rallier à
reconnaître l'afghanistan avec d'autres
pays mais pas seul c'est vraiment la
position du pakistan genre de jeux créés
à aïda a ce qu'il faut négocier avec les
talibans
déjà j'étais depuis longtemps
je me posais le négoce de l'état nous a
pas posé les talibans même aujourd'hui
gyan même aujourd'hui c'est pas les gens
avec qui on peut négocier maintenant le
problème madame qu'elles sont c'est un
problème trop politique
chose dolan dans la région ou au niveau
mondial
mais si on reconnaît les talibans il
faut être bien sûr et certain oui le
tourner à charbonnier surtout le
lan et la dernière année les gens
souffrent et l'insécurité elle était à
son top et c'est l'état les banques
faisaient
figure d et aujourd'hui elle tue elle
massacre elle tape elle frappait lui il
n'y a pas de l'ordre ce pays il n'y a
plus de loi si maintenant reconnaît
tellement en officialise cette
sauvagerie on le donne le pouvoir absolu
pour qu'elles fassent tout ce que
j'avais ils ont pas fait pour gouverner
il ne savent pas gouverner ils sont
faites pour tout y est ce tout
maintenant il faut qu'il ya un consensus
pour faire un gouvernement acceptable
pour le pauvre raison quelles en sont
les raisons de cette gouffre et en sauf
la région a bien vu que finalement
effectivement même 7 ce départ des
américains totalement chaotique on voit
bien comme vous le disiez jean-pierre
que finalement les américains
aujourd'hui non plus du tout envie
d'avoir à faire avec l'afghanistan donc
là qu'est ce qu'on fait effectivement on
négocie tout de même avec eux pour
faciliter justement les passages des ong
qui fuit pas les reconnaître alors pour
l'instant personne ne les reconnaît donc
non non non non je pense qu'une urgence
qu'est l'urgence et la population en les
enfants les enfants et des petits
afghans sont pas responsables de la
situation actuelle ils ne sont pour rien
donc il paraître normal qu'on les aide
et que s'il l'aide doit passer par un
certain nombre de concessions c'est à
dire des discussions avec les talibans
pour discuter avec la session d'hier on
lève les sanctions jean pierre perrin
alors c'est tout dépend de tout dépend
de quelle sanction enfin moi je suis pas
je peux donner de jugement moral sur ces
sur la question simplement je vois une
population qui regroupe détresse en
grande souffrance et je pense qu'il faut
absolument les dés et si il faut
négocier avec des talibans pour que
cette population soit aidée et bien
négocier des talibans ça ne signifie pas
rouvrir les ambassades ça ne signifie
pas leur donner un siège à l'onu ça ne
signifie pas simplement de la première
urgence c'est de venir en aide à la
population c'est tout je crois que c'est
simplement
je crois que l'urgence humanitaire
d'urgence humanitaire et bien bien sûr
mais d'un point de vue économique parce
que finalement sur quoi repose
l'économie aujourd'hui de l'afghanistan
sur par oppose d'économie rien sur rien
non elle avait l'afghanistan ça fait des
années qu'elle l'a qu'elle n'a jamais
rien produit même avant même avant
l'invasion soviétique et ne produisait
rien même dans les années 50 elle ne
produisait rien
simplement une agriculture à peine
autosuffisant et c'est tout qu'est-ce
qu'il rapportait de l'argent au
gouvernement simplement les aides
internationales et les points de douane
où on taxait les marchandises qui
entraient mais c'est ça qui depuis
qu'ils aident qui permettait si vous
voulez un mini re administration et
fusionner et puis les travaux la culture
dans le message
ça ne veut ça n'allait pas dans l'est
dans les caisses de l'état c'est là dans
les caisses des talibans dans les
caisses des talibans dans les caisses
des trafiquants dans les caisses des
pays voisins dans les caisses du
gouvernement afghan ce karzai qui donne
des leçons devraient bien quand même
faire attention à ce qu'il dit il à
l'ailé son frère est est considéré comme
l'un des plus grands trafiquants de
drogue depuis l'afghanistan et s'il a
été considéré comme trafiquant de drogue
et s'il l'a été c'est grâce à son appui
également donc voyez donc que karzaï
fait partie de ceux par lesquels la
catastrophe est arrivée comme comme rani
également et aussi la responsabilité des
pays occidentaux qui ont concerné ces
régimes qui les ongles installés et qui
n'ont pas mis les garde-fous nécessaires
h je conçois tout à fait de la situation
n'était pas facile mais lorsqu'il ya eu
les accords de bonn juste après la chute
des talibans il y avait un espoir en 86
à
96 où il dominait en 2001 juste après la
chute du thallium des talibans ou en
même temps grandes négociations à bonn
on invite des seigneurs de guerre qui
sont larges et j'ai vu on n'invite pas
un seul talibans parce c'est lé vaincu
certes il avait quand même leur mot à
dire il avait administré tant bien que
mal ce pays pendant cinq ans il avait
quand même leur place et peut-être qu'on
ne serait pas arrivé à cette situation
de chaos est d'accord avec vous
en tout cas quelque chose de raté à
cette époque tout était ratée tout tout
tout a été ratée je dire y'a rien qui
n'a pas été raté la société civile
certes est une réussite mais elle ne
peut pas affronter le régime taliban
elle a été créée grâce effectivement la
chute des talus à la chute des talibans
mais on lui a pas donné non plus
suffisamment de moyens pour se
développer comme elle aurait pu l'être
une inspiration dans les villes afghanes
je parle pas des campagnes à l'éducation
à une vie meilleure à vivre finalement
comme des occidentaux regardez moi j'ai
connu l'afghanistan n'y avait pas du
tout d'ascenseur ça n'existait pas
maintenant et des ascenseurs un peu
partout à kaboul bon ben c'est quand
même grâce à ces vingt années de
présence occidentale simplement l'armée
américaine commis toutes les erreurs
possibles stratégiques tactiques et puis
re il n'y a pas eu l être rock l'armée
américaine est aveuglé par l'hubris
c'était quand même elle est considérée
les avions comme des péquenots et 11 mai
puis voilà ça n'avait pas au delà des pc
des péquenots qui ont gagné sonia
ghezali est ce que d'autres pays sont
frotte les mains par exemple la chine ou
encore l'iran est ce que ils ne
reconnaissent pas ce régime mais est-ce
qu'ils n'essayent pas justement
d'exploiter il ya des ressources
naturelles extrêmement importante en
afghanistan je pense au lithium par
exemple
louis puis il ya le lydia mais il ya
énormément oui exactement de nombreuses
mines de pierres semi précieuses et et
de gadet ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
sous le précédent régime
l'insécurité en fait empêché
l'exploitation de toutes ses ressources
elle a empêché les contrats il avait
notamment dans le sud de kaboul 1 une
grande une grande mine qui sur laquelle
la chine a un contrat qui n'a jamais pu
être exploitées justement à cause de
l'insécurité et c'est vrai que les
talibans en prenant le pouvoir on en
sort est une sorte de sécurité alors
c'est pas la sécurité à 100% puisqu'il
ya toujours le groupe etat islamique et
qui mènent des attentats mais il ya tout
de même une plus grande sécurité
qu'auparavant et donc maintenant c'est
vrai que l'exploitation de toutes ces
ressources est possible et que plusieurs
pays sont évidemment intéressé c'est le
cas de l'iran voisin de la chine il ya
des discussions qui ont lieu entre ces
pays et le gouvernement taliban et eux
ils vont pouvoir vous pensez oslo dia
exploiter ce qui n'a pas été exploitable
ou exploités pendant toutes ces années
les chinois par exemple
les chinois t gothique quand on voit le
l'influencent l'impact de la chine ici
au pakistan et comment les chinois ont
réussi à signer des contrats très très
très important très intéressant pour eux
on se dit que oui effectivement rien
n'empêchera à ce que les chinois et les
talibans signaux des contrats et
puissent commencer à travailler ton
afghanistan moi je me demande dans
quelle mesure ensuite cela pourrait être
applicable est possible quand on voit
les la façon de faire des chinois par
exemple ici au pakistan finalement comme
ils le font en afrique aussi ils
emmènent leur main d'oeuvre et je ne
sais pas si ça peut se faire en
afghanistan étant donné le contexte mais
je pense que ça prendra encore beaucoup
de temps puisque il est aussi cette
question de reconnaissance de la
communauté internationale je ne sais pas
dans quelle mesure tous ces contrats
peuvent se mettre en place au vu des
sanctions internationales qui qui vise
l'afghanistan aujourd'hui
shoukria ada est ce que les talibans
pour terminer cette émission ont donc
encore des liens avec al-qaïda est-ce
qu'ils sont une menace terroriste
mondiale
aujourd'hui en afghanistan on apprend
dans des madrassas qui sont faits par
des racques année c'est à dire on est en
train d'élever des soucis d'heure or ils
sont auteurs donc l élève tout s'est su
dire pour qui donc vous dites oui oui
l'inversé les autres elle devient centre
de ils peuvent devenir le centre du
terrain avant de venir il commence à
devenir lassant d'un responsable jean
pierre péran que s'ils ont compliqué et
que tous les talibans ne sont pas
d'accord sur ce point
il ya effectivement des talibans qui
sont plus proches d'al qaïda et d'autres
qu'il souhaiterait s'en éloigner il ne
faut surtout pas considérer ma musique
me gêne un mouvement qui est sais pas il
n'y a pas de tendance au sein des
talibans je pense l'idéologie
globalement la même mais il ya ce qu'on
appelle des maras vers des fronts le
front du sud et le front de l'est il ya
une fronde née de la guerre constituent
les femmes
et ces fronts le marais en s'aimant je
pense que le front de l'ouest étape est
infiltré par l'iran par exemple le front
de l'est est beaucoup plus proche du
pakistan et des services secrets
pakistanais les gens du sud sont
peut-être plus plus autonome par rapport
au pakistan donc tout ceci on ne voit
pas leurs divergences parce qu'il des
caches remarquablement bien la famine
aussi écrase tout empêche de voir un
petit peu les subtilités entre eux mais
il y a eu effectivement il ya rameaux
des talibans qui n'est pas insensible à
l'idéologie talibane mais c'est le même
rameaux qui a les liens les plus avérée
avec les trafiquants de drogue et en
même temps les liens les plus proches
avec les services secrets pakistanais
voyez la situation est très complexe
mais oser potentiel du terrorisme
mondial ou pas terrorisme mondial je ne
sais pas peut-être que quand même le
tadjikistan doit attirer un peu les les
talibans dix ans ce régime on est un
régime faiblard le pays et
en faillite également il ya juste un
fleuve à le traverser look sus
l'amou-daria donc je crois qu'il doit y
avoir quand même une tentation d'aller
exporter un petit peu le talibanisme de
l'autre côté de de cette rivière même si
c'est la majorité de la population est
tadjik donc un peu un peu réfractaires
donc terreau possible mais dans le passé
il ya eu effectivement une guerre civile
ofac aux hadjis qui ce temps entre des
islamistes et des et le gouvernement
donc oui oui je pense qu'il ya une
aspiration vers le pacte vers le
tadjikistan ont voire deux bébés ce
temps je ne sais pas s'ils seront à même
de pouvoir mettre cette menace à
exécution frédéric joly vous pouvez
conclure cette émission
mais très rapidement juste dire que ce
qu'on a coutume de dire c'est que
balleux humanitaire et le cic
appartement n'avait eu ni stands et dans
la temporalité de la souffrance des gens
entre eux mais du point de vue à la
hauteur de la victime du point de vue
des victimes et que ce temps là il n'est
pas tout à fait celui de la politique ou
de la diplomatie mais une chose est sûre
c'est que plus le temps passe et bien
plus les afghans vont se retrouver dans
une situation encore pire que celle
qu'ils sont en train de vivre
aujourd'hui donc on ne peut qu'appeler
effectivement à ce que la politique
règle cette problématique une fois plus
et allume l'humanitaire qui parviendra
on fait ce qu'on peut avec les moyens
que l'on a mais malheureusement il faut
que ce soit vraiment un agenda politique
qui essayent de résoudre cette crise
pour les pour toute la population
rihanna en a moins
d'autres phrases comme non une phrase on
a tellement d'une part il y a les
familles mollah baradar tout les jours
de candeur qui sont 2 août et sataniques
et sont soutenus par le talent par le
pakistan et qui parle par les argens où
il vient et 14 18 lassé de notre côté
madame veuve sens auprès d'europe
question des femmes en tout cas on va
pas y revenir c'est vraiment le rusé au
moins de vous avez de les croire quand
même pour ce pays oui oui ni non
pas des talibans c'est reconnaître des
droits des femmes la démocratie et
l'avenir de l'afghanistan la démocratie
l'avenir de l'afghanistan merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous merci jean pierre
perrin merci beaucoup frédéric joly
merci saunière à soyaux ghezali
correspondante de france 24 en
afghanistan fin dans la région au
pakistan merci à vous tous deux heures
suivis reste avec nous sur france 24